lange erwartet und nicht wirklich
überraschend der austritt des
parteivorsitzenden jack morton aus der
afd der scheinbar gemäßigte weg also
bahn frei für die sogenannte liga ost
eine art ostdeutsche regionalpartei um
den rechtsaußen höcke von leuten stets
als schreckgespenst beschworen die
verunsicherung in der afc scheint gross
die einen suchen ihr heil in der
fundamental opposition die anderen in
einer machtperspektive doch von wo
sollen die herkommen die frage als
ausrufezeichen nach leuten rückzug
welchen kosten die afd jetzt in der
phoenix runde
das herz der partei schlägt heute sehr
weit rechts und es schlägt eigentlich
permanent hochfrequenz das nicht gesund
ich sehe da ganz klar totalitär anklänge
so weit die arbeiten am tag seines
austritts aus der optik und david
herzlich willkommen bei uns meine gäste
zunächst zugeschaltet ist geriet sie
waren früher managerin im daimler benz
konzern dann selbstständige
unternehmensberaterin jetzt sind sie
bundestagsabgeordnete seit dem herbst
des letzten jahres für die afg und in
der fraktion arbeitsmarktpolitische
sprecherin ebenfalls zugeschaltet hans
vorländer professor an der technischen
universität dresden und sie leitet dort
das zentrum für verfassungs und
demokratieforschung
im studium grüße ich an kathrin müller
politik redakteurin und ard expertin im
hauptstadtstudio des magazin magazins
der spiegel hier in berlin und alexander
kissler ebenfalls aus berlin und in
berlin tätig politischer redakteur im
berliner büro der neuen zürcher zeitung
sind sie eigentlich froh an leuten los
zu sein
nein das würde ich nicht unbedingt sagen
er hat uns ja viele jahre lang gute
dienste geleistet aber sagen wir mal die
außenwirkung war lange zeit sehr gute
innenwirkung kann den letzter zeit stark
gelitten insofern ist es nur
folgerichtig dass er ausgetreten ist
vorländer jetzt bahn frei für die harte
linie in der partei hat er jetzt hat
gern höcke und design haben die jetzt
freie bahn
wir zumindest in ostdeutschland aber da
ist die rückenlinie ihr schon lange
der vorhand insofern haben sich hier
noch einmal die machtverhältnisse ganz
klar gezeigt wo die
westlb die hingeht ist natürlich noch
eine ganz offene fragen für müller warum
hat den leuten so lange gezögert mit
seinem austritt und gesagt unerwartet
kann man ja nicht das ist eine gute
frage also in der partei oder außerhalb
haben sich viele schon länger gefragt
waren er den aus treten möge er
begründet das ja jetzt damit dass er
jetzt weitere anzeichen hat dass sich
sein kurs nicht durchsetzen lässt
ehrlicherweise könnte man sich schon
vorstellen dass das was mit dem
gerichtsurteil zum verfassungsschutz
beobachtungen auch zu tun hat die ja
anfang märz dauern könnte und er hat
einfach gemerkt dass er seine macht in
der partei seien acht basis verloren hat
hat die afd gerade wenn man der
auftreten im bundestag so sieht hat die
den parlamentarischen weg eigentlich
aufgegeben also die gestaltung die
mitsprache im parlament möglicherweise
auch eines tages in einer koalition will
sie eher in einer wie bisher
fundamental oppositionellen bewegung zu
hören also momentan übt sie diese rolle
einer fundamental opposition dass es
richtig ist eine sehr schrill fraktion
die also sehr scharf kontra gibt ist
momentan weder koalitionsfähig noch
koalitions will ich was sich
mittelfristig durchsetzen wird darüber
werden wir heute auch sprechen dass wird
darüber entscheiden ob sie eines fern
oder mittleren tages koalitions und
damit gestaltungs fähig sein wird
sie sind ja ein neues gesicht in der afg
sind ja eigentlich jetzt erst durch die
wahl in den bundestag in erscheinung
getreten obwohl sie schon länger im
bereich arbeitsmarkt und rentenpolitik
mitarbeiten was hat sie denn 2017
bewogen die afg einzutreten
also ich finde dass vieles in unserem
land nicht gut läuft und ich habe eine
partei gesucht indem man die chance hat
diese dinge auch zu verbessern und die
habe ich in der afg gefunden ich glaube
es ist sehr wichtig dass sich möglichst
viele bürger in der politik engagieren
denn es läuft in unserem staat doch
einiges schief
jetzt haben sie gerade diesen o ton von
jörg morgen gehört gesagt hat die das
herz der af.de das schlägt inzwischen
sehr weit rechts er höre viele
totalitäre anklänge ist da was dran oder
ist ihre erfahrung der andere
ist mir ja mit ja er hat das hat ja
gesagt viele personen die er kennt und
die vernünftig waren hätten sich
sukzessive
radikalisiert und hat das daraus
geschlossen dass sie nicht mehr all
seinen entscheidungen erfolgt sind werde
natürlich umgekehrt auch auf die idee
kommen kann seine entscheidungen in
einzelfällen sind zu hinterfragen hat er
nicht getan und da sind ihm auf einmal
ganz viele geisterfahrer entgegen
gekommen gut und ich denke denke man hat
immer noch übelgenommen dass er einen
spaltpilz in die partei herein getragen
hatte hat der antwort oder nachgedacht
die partei in zwei hälften zu spalten
das will aber keiner von uns das macht
auch keinen sinn also summa summarum
kann ich sagen er hat uns gute dienste
in den ersten jahren geleistet in der
außendarstellung und der innen
darstellung ist es dann immer schlechter
geworden und damit bleibt eigentlich
nichts anderes zu sagen als ihm alles
gute für die zukunft zu wünschen aber
sie haben ja glaube ich auch auf die
frage schon geantwortet in einem anderen
interview sie sollten den säulen der
partei noch keine rechtsradikalen
begegnet aber es gibt ja zum beispiel
diese alternative nachrichten gruppe
bayern von afg abgeordneten aus bayern
wo von umsturz und revolution gesprochen
wird eine landtagsabgeordnete sagt um
einen bürgerkrieg wird es nicht gehen
ein kandidat in dresden oder ja in
dresden sagte im bundestag müsse ein
politischer großputz zahlen er hoffe
dass er in die reinigungs private
reinkommt diese wortwahl diese
äußerungen haben aber ganz klar rechtes
gedankengut zum hintergrund wieso sehen
sie da keinen rechtsradikalismus in der
partei
man also ich sehe denn tatsächlich ist
seht ihr nicht mal in diesen äußerungen
denn ganz ehrlich gesagt wenn sie
einzelne worte auf stießen mit der lupe
vergrößern können sie praktisch in jedem
politischen chat eine mördergrube finden
also das sind doch einzelne dinge bei
uns geht es immer um worte bei uns geht
es nicht um programmpunkte es geht nicht
mehr verlassen es geht um eure zum
politischen system der bundesrepublik
ich habe das akzeptiert man spürt man im
streik zur kollision und einem
bürgerkrieg
wir greifen doch nicht die demokratie an
im gegenteil der erste satz in unserem
programm heißt wir sind überzeugte
demokraten uns geht es letztlich um
verluste an demokratie in diesem land
die wir tatsächlich sehen es gibt jedoch
einzelne autoritäre züge oder totalitäre
züge wenn sich zum beispiel bürger nicht
mehr trauen ihre walz also die wahrheit
zu sagen ihre meinung zu sagen das ist
kein gutes zeichen für gelebte
demokratie
in der bundestagsfraktion
ist im moment nicht harmonie die
fraktion hat schon drei abgeordnete
verloren es gibt jede menge ärger sie
haben da auch darüber geschrieben in der
fraktion ist dann auch ein
auseinanderbrechen der fraktion denkbar
also ein richtiges auseinanderbrechen
der fraktion kann ich nicht sehen wenn
selbst solche äußerungen jetzt nicht mal
als rechtsradikal gelb sieht man ja was
für ein klebstoff da ist nämlich der
klebstoff einfach diese partei zu
erhalten und mit dieser partei eben so
weiterzumachen wie sie jetzt eben schon
seit jahren sich eben entwickelt und
schön dass im programm so einsatz steht
papier ist geduldig da sind äußerungen
von einzelnen funktionären und auch das
was man eben sonst so fordert dann eben
doch klarer und daran kann man sehen wie
sich die fdp entwickelt hat und wo sie
heute steht und dass seine fraktion ist
immer wieder machtspielchen gibt und
auch ernsthaften ärger das ist so aber
offensichtlich gibt es ja nicht gibt ja
nicht mal jetzt woher wollten austritts
leute die ihm folgen wollen also da gibt
es offensichtlich schon den wunsch eben
in dieser partei und dieser fraktion zu
verbleiben und da eben weiter das zu
machen was man jetzt schon sehr lange
mal seine bisherigen anhänger ja zum
teil auch mit ihm unzufrieden waren die
in der parteien den letzten in der
letzten zeit agiert hat wie kessler hat
sich denn die bundestagsfraktion die ist
ja etwas dezimiert worden ich hatte aber
auch eine ganze reihe von neun
mitgliedern bekommen hat sie sich denn
radikalisiert naja es gibt ja diese
diese schöne personaltableau so wenn man
versucht jeder einzelnen personen eine
verortung innerhalb der partei
zuzuordnen nach der nähe zum
archimedische punkt dem flügel oder
nicht sie hat sich mit sicherheit nicht
verbürgerlichung das kann man schon
sagen ob sie sich im ganzen
radikalisiert hat der wage ich noch kein
urteil abzugeben ich habe halt noch mal
angeschaut das haben noch gar nicht alle
neun auch nur einmal eine rede gehalten
also mehrere abgeordnete sitzen sagen
noch keine rede gehalten einige wo ist
vermuten würde haben bisher geschwiegen
andere haben relativ zahmen reden
gehalten und die die immer oder meistens
über die stränge schlagen wir haben auch
dieses mal wieder über die stränge
geschlagen sodass ich glaube dass ich am
klima innerhalb der fraktion wenig
geändert allerdings natürlich durch die
wahlergebnisse an dem gewicht es hat ja
als einziger bundesligist bundesland
hatte thüringen ja an stimmen zugelegt
sachsen ist es stärkste trotz verlusten
die stärkste partei geworden bei der
sächsischen bundestagswahl insofern
haben sich die gewichtung regional etwas
natürlich weg vom westen und damit weg
vom tatsächlich oder vermeintlich
freiheitlichen lager verschoben das
auftreten an sich ist nach wie vor eine
mischung aus
rabauken fundamental opposition und hin
und wieder aber auch klugen und
bedenkenswerten beiträgen es ist also
wirklich sehr park
welchen eindruck haben sie von ihren
fraktionskolleginnen und kollegen jetzt
im neuen bundestag wie gesagt die
rivalin ging ja nicht so aus wie sich
das eigentlich gewünscht hatten
ich hätte mir natürlich ein besseres
ergebnis noch gewünscht aber ich bin
eigentlich positiv überrascht von meinem
kollegen in der fraktion wir haben sehr
viele kluge köpfe da die auch sehr
wertvolle beiträge leisten also es gibt
auch sehr viele vorschläge
ich sehe eben auch nicht die radikalität
wir sind alle aus dem bürgertum wir
haben alle bürger sich für karrieren
hinter uns und wenn sie so wollen haben
wir alle ein bürgerliches gesicht also
ich verstehe diese einordnung
tatsächlich nicht sie werfen uns
einzelne worte vor aber die regierung
die bundesregierung auf einzelne länder
regierung vorab stehen sogar gesetze die
nicht verfassungskonform sind und die
deswegen immer von den
verwaltungsgerichten wieder einkassiert
werden und jetzt auf die impfpflicht ist
ja mutmaßlich ein nicht
verfassungsgerichtes gesetz das geplant
wird dagegen wehren wir uns wir sind
diejenigen die auf das grundgesetz
aufpassen auch auf unseren rechtsstaat
gut so sagen ja mutmaßlich noch ist die
impfpflicht nicht verabschiedet die
allgemeine impfpflicht war ja auch noch
nicht vor dem verfassungsgericht also
genau wie genau das verfassungsgericht
reagiert muss man erst noch sehen wenn
nicht
im einsatz das ist es war ein satz von
kurzer suche man immer natürlich
sie haben widersprechen wollen hervor
länder
hervor hätte ja
ja ja danke ich meinte natürlich dort
deutlich mal widersprechen das
bundesverfassungsgericht hat vor gar
nicht langer zeit eigentlich die korona
maßnahmen und die verordnung die
aufgrund der ist zur infektionsschutz
gefällt worden sind angegriffen was uns
gemäß erklärt und nicht
verfassungswidrig
also die behauptung dass im
verfassungswidrige gesetze vom bundestag
gemacht worden sind von der alten
regierung vielleicht jetzt verlängert
auch von der neuen ist schlicht und
einfach falsch das muss man sehr
deutlich sagen dass in einzelfällen vor
den verwaltungsgerichten einzelnen
paragraphen von den ländern
verordnungen oder von allgemeinverfügung
der städte nicht bestand hatten das ist
eine große ausnahme weil ihr in diesen
einzelnen fällen der grundsatz der
verhältnismäßigkeit
zum falschen ergebnis geführt hat aber
das ist die ausnahme und nicht die regel
und insofern könne man nicht sagen dass
hier verfassungswidrige gesetze gemacht
oder durchgesetzt worden
ja ich wollte noch kurz zum bürgerlichen
kommen als ist auch hier finde ich ein
gemenge lager seit dieser kritik an den
staatlichen anti corona maßnahmen
bekommen durch die afg eine
parlamentarische repräsentation das ist
ja zunächst mal nicht verkehrt wenn man
dazu steht es gibt leute die die
komplett ablehnen und die bekommen eine
parlamentarische vertretung eine stimme
das ist ja besser als wenn diese
menschen gar nicht mehr im
parlamentarisch demokratischen raum
werden also die ofd macht immer wieder
inhaltliche punkte jetzt gerade war
diese wissenschaftliche dienste tour
vielleicht verfassungswidrigkeit des
verlängerten des verkürzten genesen
staates durch robert koch-institut
ergebnis einer anfrage an die
wissenschaftlichen dienste durch einen
fdp abgeordneten das ist völlig d'accord
dann nutzen sie ihre recht es ist
parlamentarischer usus man sollte ihn
auch keine posten vorenthalten finde ich
das andere was das bürgerliche angeht
war auf die sich auf die keinem ruht ist
das auftreten und das auftreten tft ist
weder im bundestag noch in den anderen
landesparlament bürgerlich wir haben
sehr sehr oft dauerhafte vorträge wir
haben diese masken mätzchen dass man
manchmal halbe masken trägt sie bewusst
falsch trägt und wir haben natürlich
auch eine sehr aggressive rhetorik und
da wäre ein abgeordneter wie vor zwei
wochen zu einem habig sagt er verachtet
ihn dann ist das einfach eine rhetorik
dem demokratischen raum nicht guttut wir
sollten uns nicht unsere verachtung
vorhalten oder uns in verachtung
hineinsteigern sondern versuchen im
gespräch zu bleiben und wenn die afg
eine bürgerliche partei wirklich sein
will dann muss es sich
professionalisieren und sie muss sich
vor allen dingen in den forderungen und
auch im auftreten deutlich
verbürgerlichung dirk doch gar keine
bürgerliche partei mehr das ist sie
schon seit langem nicht sie schafft es
nicht also selbst wenn sie mal auch ein
blindes huhn findet mal ein korn
irgendwie eine maßnahme kritisiert das
kann und soll sie gerne tun aber es ist
ja auch nicht so als wenn sie die
einzige partei die um die maßnahmen
kritisiert wir haben gerade auch ein
regierungswechsel gehabt vor herrn grüne
fdp vor allen dingen auch die fdp die
korona maßnahmen kritisiert und jetzt
sitzen wir in der regierung die cdu kann
auch sehr gut tun also das findet ja
auch so alle stadt und dieser versuch
von der afg alles zum mainstream zu
erklären alle parteien in einen topf zu
werfen alle medien abzulehnen juni über
staatsfonds zu
zuschreiben irgendwie bei facebook wie
das auch frau holt über ard und zdf und
damit auch über phoenix und dann aber
trotzdem hier zu sitzen das ist nicht
bürgerlich wenn man eben immer wieder
auch nicht nur rabatten haft um das mal
bei ihnen einmal zu kritisieren die ard
ist durch und durch nicht jeder einzelne
person aber in ihrer kompletten
programmatik und in ihren ausdrücken
rassistisch sie ist antidemokratisch
wenn sie das parlament so sehr verachtet
die parteien so sehr verachtet die
regierenden so verachtet sie macht die
medien schlecht sie macht behörden
schlecht sie hat den wunsch dieses
system manifest zu verändern und da ist
eben nichts was man da irgendwie noch
bürgerlich nennen könnte und wenn sie
sagt ja sie sieht ja bürgerliche
gesichter ja was ist ein bürgerlicher
gesicht die definition will ich erstmal
kennen denn für jemanden nur ein neonazi
oder jemand rechtsradikales wenn man
eine glatze hat und springerstiefel also
die 90er jahre sind vorbei und man kann
dieses gedankengut auch haben wenn man
sehr bürgerlich aussieht und wenn man
ein kariertes jackett an hat oder oder
oder und da muss ich wirklich sagen dass
das was die afg seit jahren schon macht
und gerade in der korona panini macht
hat wirklich überhaupt nichts mehr mit
demokratischem opposition zu tun meines
erachtens gut dann gehe ich das wort
wieder frei also kritik an der
inhaltlichen aufstellung nicht
bürgerlich auch in der in den in den
programmatischen punkten aber eben auch
in der außendarstellung gerade der
fraktion im bundestag muss die fraktion
da etwas tun
also isst kann sicherlich nicht schaden
wenn wir uns
professionalisieren aber ich muss ganz
strikt widersprechen wir haben eine
absolut bürger durch das programm wir
verteidigen die bürgerlichen werte wir
verteidigen die bürgerlichen freiheiten
und wir wollen uns wirklich auch die
anliegen der bürger zu eigen machen es
ist nicht nur so dass wir die probleme
artikulieren auch die favorisierten
probleme die die anderen parteien nicht
ansprechen wir bieten auch
lösungsvorschläge dafür anschauen sehen
unser programm schauen sie in unser
wahlprogramm schauen sind unser konzept
in unserer anträge wir bemühen uns
wirklich etwas beizutragen damit es in
unserem land wieder besser gewirkt denn
das wir dass es herr abgesicherte sind
vielen teilen das ist doch evident das
wissen sie auch alle und das sind die
punkte die wir adressieren
deutschland geht es so gut wie lange
nicht und wir sind besser als viele
andere länder durch die korona pandemie
gekommen die arbeitslosenzahlen sind
sich also genau das ist das was ich
meine es immer ein thema nehmen und
alles ins negative drehen alles immer
auf flüchtlinge beziehen auf migration
auf gegen den staat die regierung will
den dem armen bürger irgendwie schröpfen
und so weiter das ist keine positive
kritik
doch ich darf dazu gleich wieder was
sagen also von flüchtlingen daher habe
ich noch gar nicht geredet heute wir
haben auch viele andere probleme wir
haben viel zu niedrige renten die
österreicher bekommen 80 prozent mehr
die holländer 120 prozent mehr die die
die dänen das dreifache die schweizer
mehr als das vierfache und selbst jeder
gegner den wir gerade sehr viel geld
geschenkt haben bekommen 60 prozent mehr
rente obwohl sie sieben jahre weniger
arbeiten das sind doch offensichtlich
probleme es kommt eine riesige
altersarmut auf und zu niemand spricht
darüber das geht doch nicht diese dinge
müssen doch öffentlich gemacht werden
dass müssen lösung dafür gefunden werden
warum wenn ich allein da mit dieser
position
würden ihnen manche nicht nicht wenige
zustimmen zu dem was jetzt gerade zur
rentenpolitik sagt natürlich das
einfacher ja ja ich sage jetzt würden
das haben stehen sie nicht alleine da
das würde ja viele genau so sehen also
insofern ist das jetzt nicht nur die afg
die dazu was sagt
und gesprächen das viel viel klarer aus
wir sind auch nicht damit einverstanden
dass so viel geld an die eu
beziehungsweise viel reichere länder
weitergegeben wird wie zum beispiel
italien wo die einzelnen bürger mehr
geld haben als wir und zwar drei mal so
viel vermögen wie wir das finden wir
nicht korrekt also es gibt viele dinge
die wir nicht direkt wenden und
insbesondere sehen wir eine deutliche
verarmung unserer bürger und wir machen
uns natürlich auch sorgen um die
bürgerlichen freiheiten gut jetzt
wirklich
natürlich
und zu verfallen und schulen dabei ist
zurück aber es gibt sehr wie wir werden
wir werden da auch noch auf inhaltliche
aspekte noch kommen nicht nur die medien
nicht nur die wissenschaft nicht nur der
politische gegner beobachten die fdp vor
länder sondern der verfassungsschutz tut
das ja auch im märz soll sich
entscheiden ob die afg zu einem
rechtsextremistischen verdachtsfall für
den verfassungsschutz wird vor nichts
unser eindruck
fürchtet sicher die afd so sehr wie
genau vor dieser beobachtung durch den
verfassungsschutz kann die idee das noch
abwenden
ja ich glaube nicht weil
überwiegend doch glaube ich bei den
sicherheitsbehörden angekommen ist das
starke rechtsextreme kräfte innerhalb
der icann agieren ich sehe das natürlich
besonders deutlich aus der perspektive
ostdeutschlands und noch deutlich aus
der perspektive sachsens und wir haben
hier eigentlich nach wie vor die leute
sehr stark
in der beobachtung die auch zu dem
sogenannten flügel flügel gehörten
kalbitz röcke spielen nach wie vor eine
große rolle wir haben herrn meier den
ehemaligen richter der lange zeit hierzu
im bundestag war aber jetzt der wieder
den wiedereintritt in seinem amt als
richter begehrt dem ja auch wirklich
auch rechtsextreme einstellungen
attestiert worden sind wir sehen das auf
der straße die afg auch zu sehr
lebhaften rauen zum teil an formen
physischer gewaltsam kite grenzen der
korona demonstration aufruft ein afg
abgeordnete wollte neulich auch vor dem
haus von frau kipping der hiesigen
riesner sächsischen sozial und
gesundheitsministerin demonstrieren das
heißt eben einfach die spielregeln einer
freiheitlich-demokratischen ordnung
nicht geachtet das system wird
verächtlich gemacht und das ganz
systematisch und man kann auch
beobachten dass die lfd in
ostdeutschland aber partiell auch in
anderen regionen in anderen städten sich
jetzt noch mal weiter radikalisiert weil
auf der noch weitere rechten seite von
der afg andere gruppierung sind die ganz
eindeutig rechtsextrem ihr nach geradezu
verfassungswidrig genannt werden könnten
wie die freien sachsen beispielsweise wo
im alter npd kader unterwegs sind die
auf der straße mobilisieren wo die ard
im arm nicht vor der frage steht
hole ich die überhole ich die nach
rechts oder distanziere ich mich davon
und da gibt es ganz unterschiedliche
antworten also ich glaube dass sowohl in
den äußerungen wie im verhalten
einzelner
gehört hatte wie aber auch eine
gesamterscheinungsbild in der
derzeitigen situation
der eindruck einer sehr starken
rechtsextreme strömung innerhalb der ard
überhaupt nicht mehr von der hand zu
weisen ist und das meines erachtens der
verfassungsschutz die gesamtheit die zu
einem verdachtsfall und damit auch zur
beobachtung mit geheimdienstlichen
mitteln
kommen sich einschätzung wird die
wirtschaft noch zum schutz sicherlich
wird und das bundesamt für
verfassungsschutz hat ja nach eigenem
bekunden
viele belege gesammelt für
rechtsextremistische tendenzen besonders
aus dem bereich des sogenannten flügels
hervor länder das gerade gesagt ist der
tatsächlich die dominierende der
dominierende bereich hat er den
allergrößten einfluss oder ist das
zunächst nur einen eindruck der in der
öffentlichkeit haben weil sich die
exponenten dieses flügel für die uns
immer besonders lautstark in der
öffentlichkeit äußern also ich würde
sogar im letzten jahr anderthalb noch
eine weitere entwicklung sehen nämlich
dass die die früher für den flügel eben
vorne dran waren die partei in diese
richtung zu treiben
das ist eine sehr starke mitte gab die
diesen dieser idee von alexander gauland
folgte egal was passierte müssen einig
seien einig einig einig und das hat dazu
geführt dass auch jungen leuten im
endeffekt seine truppen verloren hat
weil eben alle sagen wir wollen diesen
zweikampf nicht mehr wir wollen uns gar
nicht distanzieren man will sich ja auch
nicht mehr von querdenkern so
distanziere hat das an ein paar tage
macht am tag darauf wieder über halb
zurückgenommen und das ist ja das was
die radikalen kräfte auch kräftig macht
also ich würde fast sagen es ist fast
mehr ein problem wenn jemand wie froh
ich dann irgendwie das auge zu macht und
sagt das ist doch alles nicht radikal
weil sie eben die leute die so radikal
sind wo sie sagt mit denen ich
eigentlich zu tun haben neben viel
stärker macht weil die dann ihr spiel
weiterspielen können und dieser flügel
und die leute die sich auch gar nicht
mehr so nennen ja also die radikalen
völkischen kräfte in der partei die
haben den vorteil dass die ganz genau
wissen wo sie hinwollen die haben eine
vision von dieser partei wenn die
anderen etwas zurückdrehen wollen wo sie
am anfang mit gelaufen sind auch leuten
hat lange das spiel mitgemacht wollte
auf listenplatz eins zur europawahl hat
mit kids und höher können die er gemacht
konnte dahinter nicht zurück war beim
flügel treffen hat da reden gehalten und
so weiter als ihnen mann auffiel dass
hat eine unterstützung seine eigene
leute verlor war es schon zu spät er
hatte die zu lange protegiert und so ist
es eigentlich geschichte aller drei
parteichefs die diese partei schon
verlassen haben und auch die geschichte
der anderen die jetzt sagen wir wollen
da gar nicht mehr so diesem lager streit
man hat sich eben arrangiert und man ist
okay damit und man sagt dann das war
aber doch nur in der einen chat gruppe
rest würde man ja öffentlich nicht sagen
aber im programm steht doch noch das
oder oder oder es gibt irgendeine form
von ausrede findet man immer und wenn
eben jemand sagt bisher noch nicht
weiter dann muss die partei verlassen
weil mit der position hatte eigentlich
keine chance wobei die wände von meint
hier auch sicherlich daher kam dass er
eben diese beobachtung durch den
verfassungsschutz abwenden wollte das
eine eine der massnahmen dazu war ja
dass der flügel ist ja schon beobachtet
worden dass dieser flügel sich plötzlich
aufgelöst hat aber welchen sinn macht
das eigentlich wenn sich der flügel um
hüppe auflöst wenn er weiterhin in der
partei aktiv ist dann ist er ja faktisch
nicht aufgelöst ist der
verfassungsschutz das war ja sozusagen
irgendeine art in verfassungsschutz
etwas hinzuwerfen auf das
offensichtlich nicht eingestiegen ist
welchen sinn hat das gemacht diese
auflösung ja ja ich weiß natürlich nicht
wie der verfassungsschutz entscheidend
wird ich gehe auch davon aus dass er die
gesamtpartei beobachten wird
tatsache ist natürlich dass es das
personal des flügels noch gibt das ist
das gedankengut des flügels in weiten
teilen der partei vor allem im osten
noch gibt dass ich also an der
programmatischen gemengelagen nichts
geändert hat und dann wird er versucht
eine art galionsfigur als ersatz für
leuten für den sogenannten mit den
gemäßigteren teil zu finden das wird
dann sehr spannend sein es soll ja ein
bundesparteitag der verschoben werden
musste soll ja im sommer stattfinden
wenn es seine durch spitze wieder geben
wird was auch unklar ist wird man da
auch euren suchen müssen dann wird man
sehen wohin sich die partei entwickelt
was den rücktritt von leuten angeht hat
er auch zwei konkrete anlässe nur kurz
zu erwähnen zum einen die nominierung
von otte als kandidat zum
bundespräsidenten wo also 90 kopiert
fühlte oder fast die ganze partei sich
die pid fehlte weil europa eben und
durchdrückte mit wenig oder keine
absprachen und zum zweiten sollte auch
zwei tage vor bekannt dass ein da seine
immunität im europäischen parlament
wegen des verdachts illegaler
parteienfinanzierung verlieren sollte
also es war auch ein hat auch zwei
seiten welche anlässe gegeben einsatz
nur noch zu ihm ich finde man muss genau
hinschauen wo es natürlich radikalismus
extremismus extremistisch ist durch die
tatsache dass eine partei bei
betrachtung der welt zu einer anderen
aussage kommt als der spiegel ist an
sich keine ist an sich keiner ist an
sich kein grund die partei zu verdammen
und die einen ist da hat ja auch viele
verschiedene meinungen natürlich in
ordnung ich meine nur einige sehr halt
die lage perfekt sie haben daten
geschildert andere sagen eben deutsche
entwickelt sich schlecht und dafür
findet man auch daten und das muss ja im
bundestag verhandelt werden das ist
nicht das problem das problem ist wie es
verhandelt wird und was sich hinter den
kulissen tut
wenn der wenn die afd die gesamtpartei
zu einem verdachtsfall wird für den
verfassungsschutz bleiben sie dann in
der fraktionen der partei
er hat sicherlich auch
das findet die gefahr größer dass die
einzige wirklich und verbal
ausgesprochen opposition eingeschüchtert
werden soll und politisch mundtot
gemacht werden soll darin sich als die
größere gefahr für unsere demokratie
sondern werden die probleme nicht mehr
so klar auf den tisch gelegt wie es
nötig ist dann finden viele menschen in
unserem land keine parlamentarische
dreht und mir also ich finde dass wir
viel gefährlicher als wenn man hier und
da ein dummes wort gesagt wird uns aber
er ist auch ein händler und wird durch
die wird dann beobachtet ist da erst mal
nicht aufgelöst und die wähler im osten
wird auch kaum abschrecken also insofern
es wird erstmal in der
mitgliederstruktur da wird etwas
auslösen natürliche beamte handwerker et
cetera die wenn dann auf abstand gehen
aber zunächst mal ist sie nach wie vor
noch im bundestag werden prozesse
angestrengt und in austin wird es eh
nicht abschrecken als wird sich so
vieles erst mal gar nicht ändern denke
ich ganz kurz ich find's
ganz interessant dass gerade die
rechtsstaat partei die selbst erklärte
jetzt irgendwie den rechtsstaat der eben
mit dem verfassungsschutz sagt da sind
möglicherweise extremistische
bestrebungen das dann komplett ablehnt
so viel zum rechtsstaat genau wie bei
den corona demonstrationen wo man
polizisten plötzlich auf stoff fordert
in den widerstand zu gehen finde ich
jetzt auch nicht so sonderlich
rechtsstaatlich im worauf die leute
mitlaufen oder sogar die proteste
anmelden
ich würde sogar sagen weiter gehen als
sie und sagen der verfassungsschutz
macht den afd lang gar nicht mehr so
viel säure es gibt ein paar wenige noch
die eben beamte sind und die dann noch
mehr pension vielleicht fürchten oder so
die sich dann überlegen müssen wie viel
sie bereit sind für die afg aufzugeben
aber das schreckgespenst hat ihre
schrecken verloren
denn die partei wartet quasi drauf weil
sie sich ja auch sehr gerne als opfer
eben inszeniert und eben dann behaupten
kann ja hier wird die versuchen die
regierung versuchte uns mundtot zu
machen so wie frau her dass gerade
gesagt hat und es geht aber eben gar
nicht mehr so sehr mein mann hat glaube
ich sowohl bei den funktionären als auch
bei den mitgliedern sagt man inzwischen
wahrscheinlich auch bei wählerinnen und
wählern das ist gar nicht mehr ein
demokratischer institutionen der wir
vertrauen so weit ist es schon gut die
ermittlungen gegen die afg sind wir
durch ein gericht unterbrochen worden
auch um chancengleichheit und
waffengleichheit im bundestagswahlkampf
herzustellen hervor länder
ja ich wollte noch ergänzen es ist ja
auch nicht so dass allein ist die
beobachtung durch den verfassungsschutz
die partei schon verbieten lassen
insofern ist die erklärung zum opfer
dieser ganzen bestrebungen auch voreilig
es ist ja erst dann könnten sie hier so
argumentieren wenn tatsächlich die
partei als verfassungswidrig verboten
würde aber das geschieht wenn überhaupt
erst nach einem langen verfahren durch
das bundesverfassungsgericht
insofern können sie weiterhin in der die
politik machen und ich denke wenn sie
mir das erlauben zu sagen wenn sie der
auffassung sind dass sie sich auch
teilweise durchaus zugestehen legitime
oppositionelle probleme zur sprache
bringen und einigen vielleicht
vernachlässigten problemen auch das
gehör bieten und auch daneben die
sprache geben im parlament dann müssten
sie sich aber sehr deutlich von den
kräften auch in der partei noch einmal
distanzieren die etwas ganz anderes im
schilde führen und das sollte eigentlich
doch von dem von ihnen so
genannten bürgerlichen kräften innerhalb
der af.de doch ein leichtes sein dass
tatsächlich auch zu tun und
das ist doch die entscheidende frage
dass man die grenzen auch sozusagen
verschwimmen lässt in diese rechte
rechtsextreme
ecke hinein weil man sich dadurch
eigentlich auch die maximierung von
stimmen und zuspruch bei wahlen erhofft
das ist ja sozusagen dass das rezept der
afg ein kleiner bürgerlicher anstrich
aber daneben auch ganz viele andere putz
truppen lassen sie mich dass man so
harte
formulieren die eben stimmung auf der
straße machen stimmung gegen das system
machen die geht es wirklich nicht um
rente
sozialausgleich oder eine vernünftige
migrations oder asylpolitik oder eine
vernünftige der politik was die econa
beschränkende maßnahmen angeht da geht
es immer nur um die zersetzung
eigentlich demokratischer strukturen
prozeduren und eben von institutionen
und die delegitimierung des systems und
davon müssten sie nicht einfach mal ganz
hart distanzieren sowie das
wollten ja auf dem parteitag in kalkar
begonnen hat wo er eigentlich versuchte
den geist den er auch mit aus der
flasche gelassen hat wieder in die
flasche zurück zu kriegen was aber
natürlich ein vergebliches bemühen war
ist diese distanzierung nötig von diesen
papieren
hervor länder da gerade angesprochen hat
nein ich sehe das alles nicht also ich
finde das zum teil auch ziemlich absurd
was sonst vorgeworfen wird also da
schaut verfassungsschutz beamten finden
ist schon verfassungswidrig dass die
migration kritisieren also was soll man
als opposition dann überhaupt noch sagen
du hast du sollen wir uns jetzt von den
gerichten einen fragenkatalog oder einen
kritik katalog vorschreiben lassen wie
opposition machen dürfen oder andere
dinge dass wenn wir nicht aufpassen wir
eines tages in der ddr 2.0 aufwachen das
ist als verfassungswidrig angeführt
worden im verfassungsschutzbericht ja
vielleicht von der verfassung geben sich
das ganz anders an demokratie
und das stimmt auch nicht sein lassen
sonst ist
also das
problem
verschlossen ist die frau die
bundesrepublik heute ist weder ddr
vergleichbaren 1981 ist natürlich nicht
aber sie sehen wir sehen natürlich
veränderungen die wir nicht gut finden
und man sagt doch so gerne wehret den
anfängen wir wollen aufpassen dass die
freiheiten nicht zu sehr eingeschränkt
werden es ist schlecht für eine
gesellschaft wenn die bürger sich daran
gewöhnen dass sie weniger freiheiten
haben und sich darauf einrichten dass
ist einfach nicht gut und wir möchten
die vollständige bürgerliche freiheit
wieder herstellen wir möchten eine freie
wirtschaft haben die nicht die register
vorgaben der regierung erfüllen muss und
und wir möchten eben lebensverhältnisse
die in den eigenen bürgern zugute kommen
wir möchten dass wieder mehr geld für
sie übrig bleibt und nicht für bürger
fremde zwecke ausgegeben wird das sind
unsere anliegen wir wollen wirklich die
bürger vertreten weil es uns nicht mehr
gefällt wie mit ihnen umgegangen wird
der vordruck bei den zuschauern oder
zuschauerin falsch hängen bleibt also
der verfassungsschutz argumentiert nicht
so dass nur weil man von migration
kritisiert man schon irgendwie rechts
oder rechtsextreme ich habe diese nein
ich habe diese gutachten gelesen das
alte zur gesamt afd und auch welche aus
den landesverbänden und da wird
argumentiert dass wenn man menschen mit
migrationshintergrund zum beispiel
abspricht deutscher sein zu können dass
man daneben extremistische tendenzen hat
weil es natürlich im deutschen recht
vorgesehen ist dass man auch mit
migrationsgeschichte
eingebürgert werden kann und dann auch
deutscher ist
migration an sich ist nicht grund wenn
man die kritisiert dass man dann
plötzlich ein rechtsextremistischer
verdachtsfall ist also bevor das falsche
bleibt ruhig
afg hat ja selbst ein staatsrechtler
beauftragt der hat einen katalog
erstellt was man besser nicht sagt um
nicht in das fadenkreuz des
verfassungsschutz zu geraten da hat man
auch das gefühl dass ich da aber viele
mitglieder afd auch im bundestag nicht
daran gehalten haben sonst hätten sie
das problem mit dem verfassungsschutz ja
nicht sie haben ja diesen staatsrechtler
selbst beauftragt
das ist richtig aber es ist natürlich
schwierig sich zu merken was man nicht
sagen
ich glaube mein leib schreiben was haben
sagen da habe ich richtig ausstehen
konflikt zu kommen
es sind wirklich zum teil also
abenteuerlich und hanebüchen und
anschuldigungen die gemacht werden
vielleicht ist hier und da mal ein
körnchen was dran aber im grossen ganzen
stimmt es schlicht nicht ja ich habe
wollen ihre eingriffe auch nicht
verstanden auf diesen chat den ich da
zitiert habe dass es ja etwas was der
bayerische rundfunk veröffentlicht hat
also mit umbruch revolution
bürgerkrieges in die einzelnen begriffe
jeder mensch kann sich darunter etwas
vorstellen und diesem zusammenhang ging
es um die beseitigung des demokratischen
rechtsstaats bundesrepublik deutschland
nein da muss ich ganz klar widersprechen
man hat sorgen dass es zu ausstellungen
bürgerkriegen kommen könnte übrigens
sorgen die auch andere und auch
geheimdienste äußern das ist ja erlaubt
sich sorgen zu machen und diese dinge zu
äußern kein mensch bei uns plant einen
bürgerkrieg oder ruft zu einem
bürgerkrieg auf das ist einfach nicht
der fall und das wäre überhaupt nicht
parteikonto wir sind auch er sich den
wirklich mal ganz deutlich sagen und wir
lehnen jede gewaltanwendung ab auch das
stimmt nicht führende flügel vertreter
von früher machen bis heute sagen sie
sätze wie wir müssen das system vom kopf
auf die füße stellen auch das ist ein
revolutionärer ansatz es gibt
massig menschen von ihnen die bei herrn
kreil sich irgendwie interviewen lassen
wer von der konservativen revolution und
einem system sturz schwafelt und es gibt
auch keinen geheimdienst meines wissens
der irgendwie sagt dass er angst hat vor
einem bürgerkrieg in deutschland und es
ist auch nicht normal demonstration zu
organisieren wo man polizisten an
schreibt dass man sich dem widerstand
anschließen solle und die seiten
wechseln soll das ist alles nicht normal
und schon gar nicht bürgerlich und wie
sie hier die maßstäbe verschieben und
überhaupt nicht mehr von das und
mitreden ist wirklich atemberaubend also
dass sie sich selbst zur gemäßigten teil
ja auch die zellen ist ja auch so ein
boarding dass ich nicht mehr verstehen
kann ist macht mich wirklich fast ein
bisschen sprachlos aber noch habe ich
ein paar worte
ich zähle mich bei afg und das deutlich
zu sagen wie sehr ich dich zu einem
speziellen teil
es geht ja um verfassungstreue oder
verfassungsverstoß
verfassungsverstoß distanz zum
grundgesetz der afd was wenn es jetzt zu
diesem zu diesem
verdachtsfall als die kommende zur
beobachtung ist ja eher wahrscheinlich
dass es so kommt erschreckt dass dann
auch diese möglicherweise bürgerlichen
reste der wählerschaft der asd ab es ist
eben haben sich das
gericht aber
sie können sie auch gleich beantworten
das darf ich auch mal ja die frage ist
natürlich immer wieder auf die reden
haben jetzt bisher großteils natürlich
von den abgeordneten im bundestag
geredet von den funktionären von den
scharmützeln dort wir haben ja auch die
vielen wähler auf die sie ansprechen
10,3 prozent bei der letzten wahl immer
noch momentanen umfragen 10 11 teilweise
zwölf also geht auch gar nicht deutlich
nach unten das heißt die afg besitzt
momentan einen auf dem politischen markt
platz ein angebot das andere offenbar
nicht abgreifen die frage ist wird
dieses angebot weniger nachgefragt war
wenn es gewissermaßen den schmutz schild
angehängt bekommt und da würde ich sagen
das hängt davon ab wie groß dieses
muschel sein wird also was genau dann
der verfassungsschutz sagen wird und es
hängt dann aber auch wirklich davon ab
inwieweit ist der afg gelingt jenseits
dieses diese verfassungsmäßigen
beobachtung eine programmatische politik
zu machen und das ist glaube ich die
große herausforderung
frau zitiert das programm das gibt es
ich kenne das auch aber wir haben
natürlich viele viele debatten auch im
bundestag wo das programm keine rolle
spielt wo es eben wirklich in einem
verächtlichen ton darum geht vorredner
schlecht zu machen insofern ist das
wirklich die frage die auch auf die
wähler abwerben wird glauben traurig ist
der partei zu dass sie trotz dieser
beobachtung hier und da noch politische
punkte setzt von denen ich möchte dass
sie im politischen diskurs vertreten
werden das ist genau die frage und wenn
man sich danach nur noch ein schießt
noch aggressiver in der rhetorik dann
wird man natürlich irgendwann
verschwinden und da hat natürlich herr
morgen in kalkar recht gehabt immer noch
enthemmter immer noch eins draufzusetzen
ist auf dauer einfach kein
erfolgsversprechendes programm abseits
einer kleinen politischen blase am rand
dann sie irgendwann bei der 6 7% oder
bei der abo wurde das bedeutet dass die
ijv dem falle einer beobachtung durch
den verfassungsschutz dann sich ein
stück weit auch zurücknimmt um nicht zu
sehr da im feuer zu stehen
also ich weiß jetzt nicht genau was sie
nicht zurücknimmt machen
sagte dass sie eigentlich relativ dann
das so sagen jetzt auch öl ins feuer
gießen danach und dann erst recht diese
radikalisierung vorantreiben die ja
wiederum für den schallschutz für den
verfassungsschutz ja auch der anlass war
sie zu beobachten
also wir treiben sicherlich keine
radikalisierung voran wir sind auch
nicht war die kabel werden aber kurs
halten wir werden weiter unbeirrt unsere
grundrechte verteidigen die abwehr
richtete der bürger sind gegen einen
übermächtigen staat und wir werden uns
auch nicht einschüchtern lassen sondern
weiter getreu unserem motto reagieren
wurzer wahrheit das heißt wir machen
weiter wir werden uns nicht
einschüchtern lassen weil das
anthropozän war ja deutschland aber
normal auf dem letzten parteitag und
letzten wahl und da sieht man momentan
recht wenig von diesem normalen
deutschlandbild was praktisch nur
stattfindet auch plakataktionen und da
muss ja auf die schon fragen soll will
wie das zusammengehen soll für
normalität eingehen und gleichzeitig an
normale sitten gebräuche und drehte form
im bundestag und andere städtische
einzuführen also das ist wirklich das
ist schon eine ganz große lücke zwischen
zwischen behauptungen angebot
in einem beitrag gesagt perspektivisch
möchte die afg auch an der regierung
beteiligt werden nicht nur in der
opposition sein wenn man sich das
programm an sieht auch den derzeitigen
zustand der partei auch die politische
orientierung ist das noch im bereich des
möglichen
das kommt drauf an wie stark die partei
wird und ob sie überhaupt in eine solche
position hineinkommt wo sie eine
machtoption haben könnte
natürlich zunächst einmal nach
ostdeutschland denken in sachsen
thüringen oder sachsen-anhalt aber wir
haben gesehen dass
bei den letzten landtagswahlen in diesen
ländern die hf die dann doch hinter den
anderen entweder spd oder cdu auch jetzt
in schleswig-holstein
mecklenburg-vorpommern
zurückgeblieben ist also das potenzial
das wissen wir aus befragungen der afg
ist im prinzip ausgereizt er da kommt
nicht mehr sehr viel und das ist aber
doch in manchen regionen gerade im süden
ostdeutschlands ein relativ starres
potenzial von fast 25 prozent der
wahlbevölkerung und die da gelingt es
der halb die eigentlich eher nicht mit
konstruktiven vorschlägen diese menschen
zu adressieren und zu mobilisieren
sondern durch schüren von hass auf die
politischen institutionen und das
politische personal das typische anti
establishment anti institutionelle
moment das wird geschürt das haben wir
auch selbst nochmal untersucht in der
korona geschichte die hat er wirklich
schwierigkeiten die war er zunächst für
die harten masten haben soweit schutz
bürgerlicher freiheitsrechte frau i sie
hat das hier unterstützen hat sie
gesehen dass sie da nicht wirklich an
zuspruch gewinnt sondern dass die
regierungsparteien eigentlich den
vertrauens zuschuss bekommen und dann
ist sie umgeschwenkt und hat sich auf
einmal ihr herz für die freiheit
entdeckt und das hat sie sozusagen
gekoppelt genau wie sie es auch gesagt
haben weil die elite die regierung die
macht die bürgerlichen freiheiten
kaputter ist keine klare sachliche
auseinandersetzung die sie hätten führen
können die fdp das hier ein bisschen
differenzierter vorgetragen und hat da
ist ja auch belohnt worden bei der wahl
aber sie schüren den hass und das ist
glaube ich der der punkt dass in teilen
deutschlands in ostdeutschland die
partei relativ stark verwurzelt ist aber
nur in dem potential derjenigen die sich
von dem system schon entfremdet haben
und die
dachten eigentlich auch gar nicht dass
die partei eine konstruktive
regierungspolitik betreibt das ist die
pure opposition ist die pure widerstands
gestik und die wird auch bewusst
geschürt das können sie gar nicht anders
sagen das lege ich jedes mal wenn ich
solche demonstrationen besucher auf den
straßen und plätzen und ich reise viel
durch die gegend und gucke mir das an
deshalb stimmt das nicht das mögen sie
vielleicht in bayern anders beurteilen
aber im osten der republik sehen die
drachen ganz anders aus deshalb es kann
ja sein dass wir vorne bleiben sich
leider in die versuchung kommt eine eine
regierung zu
begleiten aber im osten frau vor ihr
einsatz zu jeder zeit am ende der
sendung dazu
zu dem was wir vorhergesagt haben ja
also wir sind kein hat das liegt uns
jedenfalls waren das wollen wir nicht
wir glauben an die demokratie und wir
glauben machen die demokratischen
institutionen wir wollen sich verbessern
wollen sie effizienter machen wir wollen
sie wieder bürgernäher machen das sind
unsere ziele und da werden wir weiter
kurs attraktive
regierungsbeteiligung ganz weit weg ganz
toll wetter wo sie stark im osten da ist
die noch stärker fundamental opposition
und da wo sie etwas weniger fundamental
opposition ist hat sie zu wenig stimmen
insofern ist in dieser generation keine
regierungsoption auch nur denkbaren
ich bedanke mich sondern am ende der
sendung bei ann kathrin müller bei
alexander kissler zugeschaltet bei
weil frau ruhigere tory entschuldigung
und bei herrn vorländer von der
technischen universität in dresden die
zuschauer morgen in der phoenix runde
olympia in peking wie umgehen mit china
es folgt phoenix der tag mit einer
schale darin unter anderem die
einstufung von atomkraft und von gas als
klimafreundlich heute bei der
europäischen kommission bleiben sie bei
uns
[Musik]